o lado pessoal de quem fala mudar que
sejam muito bem vindos já é mais um
vídeo e os tragos de que o primeiro
vídeo e 2015 e espero que essa passagem
de ano tenha sido muito por amy foi
passado em casa e beber água
obviamente estou a brincar noel na
passagem de ano esteve em casa então
elas têm pessoal é o estrado de que três
montanhas russas que os políticos de
forma completamente aleatória vi em
outros canais mas o que é isto dentro de
uma sala gigante osso tipo - consuma não
sou o harry plantas boa
o cade o gasto é muito real pessoal e
schwenck feito no rio em ti não seja
ético um dos melhores clientes que apure
com rigor e agora pega o hull não pobres
é muito real dos indivíduos
acho que a cabeça meu não pode não pode
ter uma barbie capital o que consegui
epic games ok go go com um brutal em
2009 o lixo como é que é possível eu já
chegamos ao fim e foi arrancada agora na
itália uma subida em uma guerra pela
câmera go to fora da cadeia
o gol não não o esposo que meu vôo e sim
na barriga
estamos aqui na segunda montanha russa
esta chama se boca no call center ou
seja deve ser tipo uma montanha russa
dentro de um vulcão apesar deste por ser
tipo o espaço alguma coisa assim precisa
crescer tudo ok o look pitt não quero
que me pedir pra nada mesmo querendo não
tenha rústica gravar o que estão votando
o google só vou sentir o calor nem eu
dou sentir o calor mel estava o tal está
muito real meu gosto
muita calma claro que tudo o que nos dá
mais pra ficar outra
o preço do mesmo tipo de look ocorre o
evento
a mãe calma bandeirantes favor e tá tudo
bem agora em pronto o que é isso em
produto no google china não tinha e não
um carnê não vai ter muito rap nenê
voltou sentir aquela cena na barriga é o
céu estava totalmente está muito brutal
ainda buscam um gogo eu fui falar mas
pagariam anda mais rápido ou sol eu
tomar ganhar a cadeira porque parece
mesmo que o coloquei meu meu apelo vou
dar essa volta toda a seu fim está
dependente do pt dirceu enfim me hoje do
deixou y como é que se chama e cá
estamos nós pessoal na terceira montanha
russa e esta brutal e os arquivos de
garota e basicamente nós vamos ter uma
missão enquanto estamos a andar de
montanha russa e nós vamos ter que
destruir barris enquanto andamos na
montanha russa está brutal pessoal na
largada lá o meu a escola foi de 53 do
tanque conseguir passar esta linha média
de 53 barris que lá e só por ser fácil
mas não é pessoal do técnico cuca
enquanto não consegue virar assim o
discurso mil euros querem que eu faça
coisas um silas iam embora o pirata
coisa de paul allen respondeu vou
aproveitar e ibaraki tochigi e yamanashi
e isso é muito difícil pois muitos
cavaleiros vai abrir e e que dentro do
tipo tarso entre pessoal sério garante
que não tenha constam ontem é equipar os
três vivem também porque está ao meu
lado água
nem assim tomou conta do fundo toca à
imprensa
ok mas você estou e um jovem de talento
também manhã o gato
ana é certo meu isso sei você tem um já
não é mau porque eu ainda tenho a
oportunidade é isso ai julgado dar de
agora é parte em que o sporting super
rápido lê não tá aí pra galera está
possuída força a roy transformará em
gaza após ler e conhecer moro metas não
ainda comem só pessoal comenta e querem
ver mais nem foi campeão e traz não há
qualquer mais bullish mas vocês porque o
tanque e meu carro eu não posso perder
essa oportunidade
lá não existem aqui eu caí com 54
especial o plo pelé não tinha visto isto
mantém meu futuro um ponto mais alto
agora eu estou na banda do pirata
então é isso ao justificar porque com
este vídeo espero que vocês tenham
gostado e se querem ver mais vídeos
assim deste gênero como montanhas russas
e coisas assim de mais radicais de gol
embaixo pessoal comentem deixa o vosso
apoio like favorito fiquem bem e até a
má da foca em próxima um militar e
chegou a parceira cantaram o que é mau